madame la ministre madame la rapporteur
cherguilaine mes chers collègues nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour vous
auditionner madame la ministre
dans un cadre
double
premier cadre et c'est celui
effectivement de l'audition finale j'ai
envie de dire et c'est normal bien
normal de vous laisser
le dernier mot de la mission
d'information
voulue et créer à l'initiative du groupe
RDSE du Sénat qui a été constitué le 1er
mars de cette année dont nous rendrons
je vous le dis c'est un scoop
le rapport le 13 juin donc vous n'aurez
plus longtemps à patienter mais il faut
quand même bien quand vous additionne
avant d'en écrire totalement les
conclusions enfin ce genre de choses que
nous pratiquons au Sénat nous avons eu
un rythme assez soutenu et nous avions
commencé nos auditions en invitant la
délégation
collectivités locales du Sénat et nous
concluons en invitant la délégation
aussi au-delà de l'addition
d'information car il y a des missions
d'information ponctuelles il y a nos
délégations permanentes et nous
inscrivons non pas dans un temps court
une mission comme ça mais dans un temps
long que nous
affectionnons particulièrement au Sénat
et je salue en particulier la présence
du Premier Vice-Président de la
délégation à savoir il estimable Rémi
Cointreau
qui arrive
c'est bien fait c'est très organisé
c'est tout ça est très organisé nous
avons répété deux semaines avant madame
la ministre et je voulais vous le
signaler le triple aérien triple
objectif à cette mission chers collègues
vous en souvenez mais je le rappelle
d'une part apprécié si l'impact des
décisions de l'État sur les finances
locales est suffisamment bien évalué en
amont
notamment en concertation parfois avec
les yeux locaux
porter deuxièmement un diagnostic qui
est une analyse objective de la
situation quelque chose d'un peu à plat
si vous le voulez et autrement formulé
et puis nous essaierons comme dorénavant
le rapport de notre collègue et amis la
vice-présidente Pascal Grigny elle avait
rappelé si on formulé une dizaine de
recommandations par une cinquantaine
parce que un moment voilà
abondance de bien de nuit pas mais voilà
qui fait fort partout fait fort nulle
part disait mon colonel cette audition
donc est ouverte au moment de la
dégueulation collective des territoriale
et retransmise je vous le dis en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat et fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu écrit j'en ai
terminé et donc la parole est à mon avis
et collègues bien tempête merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues notre mission
d'information créée dans le cadre du
droit de tirage de mon groupe du RDSE
est né d'un Costa de nombreuses
décisions unilatérales de l'État
augmente les charges des collectivités
ou en diminue les ressources
quel est l'état des lieux précis d'abord
sur les normes réglementaires nous
constatons que les imposent
collectivités locales des contraintes de
plus en plus abondantes au risque de
submerger les élus
nous relevons la progression inquiétante
de des codes qui régissent l'activité
des collectivités on pense notamment au
code général des collectivités
territoriales qui a triplé de volume
entre 2002 et 2023 nos collègues
Francoise Gatel et Rémi pointeaux auteur
d'un rapport récent sur le sujet
pourront sans doute compléter mon propos
cette inflation normative a des
répercussions financières directes ou
indirectes sur la conduite des
politiques publiques locales
en particulier cette inflation entraîne
la modification le report voir l'abandon
des projets portés par des collectivités
or le temps c'est de l'argent surtout en
cette période d'inflation
ce dont le rapport d'activité du cnen
les normes réglementaire représente en
2022 un coup net de 2 milliards et demi
d'euros pour les collectivités cette
situation peut être difficilement
soutenable financièrement notamment pour
les plus petites communes aux ressources
limitées
les élus nous ont donné de nombreux
exemples concrets dans le rapport y
compris les plus ubuesques comme celui
du poulailler mobile qu'un maire des
Yvelines tente désespérément d'installer
sur sa commune et bien sûr nous pensons
aux ânes qui imposent des contraintes
importantes pour nos élus nul besoin de
développer je crois les élus nous ont
aussi parlé de l'impact en termes de
ressources humaines en effet d'une part
certaines collectivités doivent recruter
des juristes pour faire face à la
complexité de la réglementation d'autre
part de nombreux élus ont des
difficultés de recrutement dans certains
secteurs où les normes sont trop
complexes
c'est pourquoi nous devrons nous devrons
être attentifs au sujet au suivi
pardonne de la charte d'engagement
signée par le Sénat et le gouvernement
le 16 mars dernier charte dans
l'objectif et de lutter contre les
conséquences de l'infraction normative
mais cette situation préoccupante ne
concerne pas que les normes
réglementaires les élus nous ont aussi
parlé des décisions budgétaires de
l'État prise dans le cadre des diverses
lois de finances cette décision concerne
à la fois les ressources et les charges
des collectivités
d'abord concernant les ressources en
constat s'impose
les élus se perdent dans le maquis des
règles applicables quelques
illustrations entre 2010 et 2023 plus de
70 décisions ont été prises concernant
la fiscalité locale
un autre exemple l'usage des dotations
d'investissement des etr décident des
Sid et de plus en plus concrets aux
critères nationaux s'ajoutent souvent
des critères locaux fixés par des
préfets troisième exemple les modalités
de répartition de la DGF repose sur de
trop nombreux critères mal compris des
élus locaux
voilà pour les ressources ensuite
concerne les charges concernant les
charges citons quelques exemples
d'impact négatifs de décision de l'État
sur les finances locales coût de la
revalorisation du point d'indice un
milliard et demi d'euros en 2023 pour
les seules communes et leurs
regroupement coût de la revalorisation
du RSA 240 millions d'euros en 2023 pour
les départements
à cela s'ajoute la volonté de l'État
d'encadrer les dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités depuis
les contrats de Cahors ces difficultés
sont accentuées par l'explosion des
dépenses de matières premières tous les
ingrédients sont malheureusement réunis
pour décourager les élus privés dans
leur pouvoir d'agir
madame la ministre face à cette
situation préoccupante notre mission
envisage plusieurs recommandations la
première piste serait la fusion entre le
CFL et de cnen comme vous le savez le
président du CNN du CFL ont appelé à la
mise en place d'un défenseur des
libertés locales ici du regroupement de
ces deux estences cette idée nous paraît
très intéressante puisque cette nouvelle
autorité quelle que soit son application
pourrait alors améliorer le dialogue
état collectivité mieux évaluer l'impact
des décisions de l'État sur l'équilibre
des finances locales et travailler bien
sûr les droites concertations avec le
Sénat
naturellement cette nouvelle instance
devrait être dotée de moyens humains et
financiers renforcés la deuxième piste
améliorer le dialogue entre l'État et
les collectivités dans les territoires
deux axes nous paraissent prioritaires
mettre en place à titre expérimental
dans certains départements des
conférences de dialogues entre l'État et
les collectivités territoriales placées
sous les gîtes des préfets ou des
sous-préfetés ces installs seraient
compétentes notamment pour donner un
avis dans les sur les cas complexes
d'interprétation des normes générateur
de coûts pour les collectivités
territoriales pour donner toute son
efficacité à ses conférences de dialogue
il conviendrait de donner au préfet
autorité sur l'ensemble des services de
l'État et de renforcer son rôle en
matière de conseils d'ingénierie auprès
des petites communes
la troisième piste serait simplifiée la
procédure relative au droit de
dérogation reconnu au préfet la première
ministre a pris récemment des positions
sur ce sujet vous pourrez sans doute les
préciser devant notre mission la
quatrième piste serait prévoir que les
décisions de l'État impactant les
finances locales doivent entrer en
vigueur avant de vote des budgets locaux
et non en cours d'exercice il s'agit de
permettre collectivités notamment de
petites tailles d'anticiper les réformes
de l'État dans leur préparation
budgétaire
et en fait la cinquième piste serait en
application du principe qui décide P
nous souhaiterions un réexamen régulier
des trois des droits à compensation pour
tenir compte de l'aggravation des
charges liées aux nouvelles compétences
que l'État a décidé de décider pardonne
de confier aux collectivités on pense
bien sûr à la gestion des collèges et
des lycées qui sont compensés au coût
historiques
en somme un dialogue responsable état
collectivité doit permettre de
distinguer entre les dépenses
strictement nécessaires et les dépenses
d'opportunités cette distinction est
d'autant plus importante dans certains
cas des collectivités font face à une
hausse exogène sur laquelle elles n'ont
aucune prise comme le RSA
je serai pas plus longue madame la
ministre contenu de nos de nos horaires
très contraints je vous donne donc la
parole et vous remercie d'avoir donné
suite à notre invitation bien sûr
[Musique]
de nos collègues donc j'invite à
bénéficier en levant la main classique
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la rapporteur cher Guilaine mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je suis très
heureuse d'être avec vous cet après-midi
sur la mission d'information relative à
l'impact des décisions réglementaires et
budgétaires de l'État sur l'équilibre
financier des collectivités donc vous me
remercier c'est bien normal je prends du
plaisir à venir échanger avec vous et
répondre à vos questions le mieux
possible cette mission d'information
participe en effet pleinement du rôle de
contrôle et d'évaluation du Sénat est
constitué un sujet particulièrement
transversal en matière de finance locale
et de collectivités territoriales mais
avant d'en venir au sujet qui ne réunit
aujourd'hui vous me permettez mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs d'adresser
toutes mes félicitations monsieur le
sénateur Jérôme Bacher monsieur le
Président qui fête me dit-on aujourd'hui
c'est 50 ans
vous verrez quand vous avez mon âge vous
allez vous venez
pour en revenir à l'objet de la mission
vous souhaitez plus particulièrement
aborder plusieurs aspects le premier
tout d'abord vous souhaitez évaluer
l'impact de l'inflation des normes
réglementaires sur les collectivités
plus particulièrement sur les plus
petites d'entre elles et en milieu
rurales dans les ressources techniques
et financières et juridiques vous avez
dit sont extrêmement limités je souhaite
ici saluer la qualité du rapport des
sénateurs Françoise Gatel et Rémy
Pointreau vous l'avez souligné madame le
rapporteur aussi sur l'addiction au
norme qui invite à oser une thérapie de
choc nous aurons très probablement
l'occasion d'y revenir dans nos échanges
j'extrais d'ores et déjà un chiffre de
ce rapport qui me paraît assez
révélateur des enjeux le code général
des collectivités territoriales donc
notre CGCT
silence
notre CGCT a triplé de volume en 20 ans
c'est un extrait de votre rapport madame
la sénatrice madame
entre 2002 et 2022
illustrant notre responsabilité que je
qualifierai de collective gouvernement
et Parlement de vouloir toujours plus
légiférer sans véritablement nous
interroger collectivement sur la
nécessité de moins et mieux légiférer je
pense que nous pouvons identifier
plusieurs facteurs qui expliquent cette
inflation des normes
l'augmentation des compétences des
collectivités territoriales qui ont vu
leur champ d'action élargie au fil des
années le CGCT s'étoffe ainsi
progressivement des nouvelles
compétences transférées de l'État vers
les collectivités territoriales donc
l'augmentation des compétences peut-être
un des facteurs en deux la
multiplication des lois et des
règlements qui ont créé de nouveaux
dispositifs et procédures à respecter je
pense par exemple à la création de
l'intercommunalité au disposition
relatives à la parité
à la création des communes nouvelles il
s'agit de répondre par la loi une
demande des élus et des politiques en
troisième facteur enfin la
complexification du service juridique
qui a rendu l'interprétation des textes
de plus en plus difficiles et la
nécessité parfois de les préciser par la
loi et le règlement donc on voit que
l'augmentation des compétences des
collectivités territoriales peut être un
facteur intéressant à explorer
la multiplication des lois et des
règlements aussi et la complexification
du service juridique aussi
deuxièmement vous souhaitez madame la
rapporteur également faire un focus sur
les décisions budgétaires de l'État qui
pèse sur les dépenses des collectivités
qui plus est dans le contexte de crise
énergétique et d'inflation que nous
connaissons encore un second chiffre du
rapport de Madame Gatel et Monsieur
Pointreau le coût pour les collectivités
vous l'avez cité madame la rapporteur
qui est estimé par le rapport environ 2
milliards d'euros au cours du précédent
quinquennat ce chiffre est similaire à
celui du dernier rapport d'activité du
Conseil national d'évaluation des normes
qui évalue le coût à 2,5 milliards
je tiens toutefois à rappeler que si les
décisions prises par l'État peuvent
avoir des conséquences sur les dépenses
des collectivités il ne faut pas oublier
que l'État verse chaque année au
collectivités territoriales près de 55
milliards d'euros les dotations de
l'État représentent une par importante
des budgets de fonctionnement des
collectivités permettent aussi de
financer des projets d'investissement
tels que la construction des cols de
route ou d'équipements sportifs sans le
soutien financier de l'Etat de
nombreuses communes ne pourraient tout
simplement pas assurer leur mission de
service public vous seriez étonné que je
ne vous le dise pas de plus il ne faut
pas oublier non plus que l'État est
également un partenaire important des
collectivités territoriales dans de
nombreux domaines que ce soit dans le
domaine de la sécurité de la culture ou
encore de l'enseignement l'état
travaille en étroite collaboration avec
les élus locaux pour assurer la qualité
des services publics offerts aux
citoyens ainsi l'État un rôle à jouer en
tant que financeur et partenaire des
collectivités territoriales et je pense
qu'il ne faut pas opposer l'un et le
second sans rappeler les liens qui les
unissent
la crise a permis d'illustrer pleinement
le rôle de l'État pour soutenir les
collectivités les plus en difficulté
pour les aider à faire face aux dépenses
indudes par la crise sanitaire et par
l'inflation enfin vous souhaitez dans
une approche préventive et non
uniquement curative à laquelle j'adhère
pleinement aborder la question de
l'évaluation des normes en amont de leur
adoption
ce qui renvoie la question de la qualité
de la sincérité des études d'impact des
projets de loi ainsi qu'à la
démonstration de leur nécessité trop
souvent collectivement nous sommes
tentés de répondre à une difficulté par
l'édiction d'une nouvelle norme je veux
aussi rappeler dans mes propos
liminaires que le sujet n'est pas
nouveau des actions déjà été entreprises
par les précédents gouvernements pour
tenter de limiter l'inflation normative
et simplifier la vie des collectivités
territoriales si l'on se donne un recul
d'une petite dizaine d'année on peut
notamment mentionner quelques actions
tout d'abord le déploiement de voler
collectivités dans le programme de
simplification 2012-2017 construit à la
suite de l'annonce du choc de
simplification du président de la
République de l'époque je note que l'on
retrouve cette notion de choc que vous
mentionnez dans votre rapport
Madame et Monsieur les sénateurs
deuxièmement la signature en 2016 d'une
charte de partenariat entre le Sénat et
le Conseil d'évaluation des normes
visant à renforcer la coordination de
leurs actions respectives au bénéfice de
la simplification normative
troisièmement l'instauration 2017 de la
règle du 2 pour 1
par circulaire du Premier ministre selon
laquelle la création de toute nouvelle
norme réglementaire doit être compensée
par la suppression ou à minimale à
simplification de deux normes de même
niveau je sais que le président du
Conseil national d'évaluation des normes
veille à son respect chaque fois qu'il
le peut par ailleurs le rapport public
annuel de la Cour des comptes consacrée
cette année au bilan de 40 ans de
décentralisation après un premier bilan
déjà réalisé en 2009 confirme ce besoin
de clarification de la répartition des
compétences entre État et collectivité
d'une part et entre les différents
échelons des collectivités d'autre part
mais tournons-nous désormais vers
l'avenir monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur dans le cadre de votre
mission vous allez d'ores et déjà
auditionner les présidents de deux
instances qui jouent un rôle déterminant
en matière d'évaluation et de contrôle
des normes applicables aux collectivité
je veux bien sûr parler d'Alain Lambert
président du Conseil national des normes
et André Le Niel président du CFL de
notre comité des finances locales au
cours de cette audition nous aurons
l'occasion d'approfondir les différents
points que vous souhaitez évoquer
j'identifie pour ma part d'ores et déjà
quatre sujets majeurs qui pour certains
regroupent deux de vos recommandations
j'ai bien noté qu'il y en avait 10 mais
quatre sujets majeurs la qualité du
dialogue entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales premièrement
nous aurons ainsi l'occasion de revenir
si vous le souhaitez mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sur une
proposition qui vous est je le sais cher
à savoir la mise en place de conférences
de dialogue état collectivité
territoriale au niveau local
deuxième sujet majeur le besoin d'une
plus grande visibilité sur les travaux
gouvernementaux concernant les
collectivités et les textes en gestation
à ce sujet je veux rappeler que l'agenda
territorial
mentionné porté par Christophe béchum
mentionné dans la charte et sur lequel
travail sur lequel je l'accompagne bien
sûr mentionné dans la charte pour la
simplification signée le 16 mars entre
le Sénat et le gouvernement et
officiellement lancer le 12 avril 2023
par la première ministre constitue
précisément la réponse du gouvernement à
ce besoin de meilleure visibilité mais
nous pourrons évidemment en parler
troisième enjeu la question des
modalités de compensation des transferts
de compétences le sujet nous le savons
tous non seulement politiquement
sensible mais aussi techniquement et
juridiquement complexe nous y
reviendrons bien sûr à votre convenance
dans les échanges à venir mais ce sujet
a déjà été longuement évoqué par le
Sénat qui s'est déjà exprimé lors de
l'examen de plusieurs propositions de
loi et contre la vie du gouvernement en
faveur d'une revalorisation au coût
historique
quatrième enjeu le rôle du préfet dans
l'application des normes et leur impact
sur les collectivités le sujet vaste là
aussi plusieurs sujets seraient à évoqué
du pouvoir de dérogation du préfet au
renforcement de son rôle d'appui en
ingénierie auprès des petites
collectivités sur ce point je ne saurais
conclure mon intervention limitaire sans
vous assurer de ma détermination à faire
de France ruralité
ce programme de politique publique un
vecteur clé de renforcement du rôle et
de la capacité à agir de l'État en
faveur des plus petites communes
notamment rurales ce programme sera
dansé par la première ministre avant la
fin du mois de juin je vous remercie
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pour votre écoute que je
qualifierai d'attentif donc je vous
remercie chaleureusement et je suis à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions merci Madame la Ministre tout
d'abord déjà d'avoir respecté le temps
vous savez cette marque de fabrique du
Sénat quand même elle rappelait notre
bon président Gérard Larcher qui nous
attend manqué tout à l'heure aux
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
est-ce que on va commencer tout de suite
alors rémi a demandé la parole mais
Françoise est-ce que voilà parce que tu
t'es un tout petit peu enfin bon je ne
dis rien
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
merci
messieurs madame et monsieur le
rapporteur et madame la ministre c'est
vrai que ce sujet était tout à fait
important et je vous remercier donc le
Président bachel et Madame la rapporteur
nous avoir convié et d'avoir fait en
sorte que la délégation des
collectivités soit aussi présente comme
nous l'avions été d'ailleurs à votre
première
réunion audition avec le président Alain
Lambert le 8 mars dernier et je vais
rappeler que nous avons avec ma collègue
présidente de la délégation
travailler sur le sujet puisqu'on a fait
un rapport avec un tri un titre qui
était un peu provocateur puisque c'était
face à l'addiction normes osant une
thérapie de choc
et on a on a failli aller un peu plus
loin parce que
on
parlait de harcèlement textuel mais bon
on n'a pas osé d'aller jusqu'à ce point
et pour passer pour passer des des
paroles aux actes donc
[Rires]
et pour passer des paroles aux actes on
a fait donc le 16 mars dernier les états
généraux de la simplification avec on
avait le ministre monsieur Béchu qui
était présent et qui ont abouti une
signature qu'on peut appeler historique
puisque en a signé un engagement avec
une charte de la simplification au norme
applicables aux collectivités locales
donc je on espère que la signature de
cette charte va nous obliger un petit
peu à mettre la douce sur les
normes
sachant que on a fait une consultation
qui a été menée au Sénat par les élus
locaux en 2023 et on a constaté que
véritablement
l'inflation normative complexifie
beaucoup les les projets locaux
retardent la réalisation donc ça fait
des points de de croissance en moins et
augmente le coût de façon significative
comme vous l'avez dit madame la ministre
ou monsieur le rapporteur c'est vrai que
les normes réglementaires représentent
en
2022,5 milliards d'euros ça a été
pour les collectivités c'était confirmé
par de nombreuses nombreux rapports et
on a prévu aussi au sein de la
délégation que le Sénat exerce une
fonction de veille et d'alerte
d'ailleurs c'est inscrit dans la charte
d'engagement alors madame Amy on espère
que tous ces rapports toutes ces
prévisions que nous avons effectuées au
travers
les nombreuses auditions d'ailleurs nous
avons eu avec l'AMF la MF qu'on puisse
passer des paroles aux actes parce que
c'est vrai que on constate quand même
que il y a non seulement le le flux des
normes qui continuent de prospérer mais
il y a le stock qu'il faut aussi on nous
parle aujourd'hui alors je sais plus si
c'est 450
000 normes mais ça fait 10 ans qu'on
parle de 450 000 on doit dépasser des
largements les 500 000
le fait qu'on légifère de trop c'est
vrai que la France est un pays qui
légifère trois fois plus que les autres
pays l'Allemagne l'Angleterre
l'Italie et ça c'est un vrai sujet
il y a le problème de la sincérité des
études d'impact et souvent qui sont
faites en urgence
[Musique]
le cnen est parfois saisi deux ou trois
jours avant
de pour l'étude du texte et ils ont pas
toujours le temps ni les moyens
d'ailleurs il y a un problème de moyens
dédié au CN qui ne fonctionnent pas il
faut vraiment que qu'on leur donne
davantage de moyens puissent pour qu'il
puisse exercer leur mission et puis
pendant quelques pendant un mandat je
crois je sais plus quel mandat il y a eu
un ministre de la simplification
[Musique]
plusieurs oui ou Jacques Chirac
également je pense que ça serait utile
peut-être d'ajouter à votre compétence
madame la ministre le domaine de la
simplification des normes ce qui serait
tout à fait intéressant pour suivre au
sein de votre cabinet tout le flux qui
arrive en toujours en nombre voilà c'est
simplement les propos que je voulais te
dire madame la ministre en espérant que
vous vous aurez une écoute attentive à
tous ces problèmes normatifs merci à
vous
alors maintenant que la présidente a pu
reprendre son souffle du essai de la
parole et puis après j'ai déjà deux
autres orateurs
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapportant merci beaucoup de votre
invitation et cette énergie
entre la délégation et la miction on
sait travailler avec intelligence au
Sénat madame la minis je vous salue
alors tout d'abord vous avez dire juste
titre que l'État était partenaire des
collectivités moi je pense que c'est
plus que ça et c'est le préambule que je
voudrais poser l'action publique repose
sur deux piliers l'État et les
collectivités et on a trop tendance à
cultiver une forme d'unijambisme fort
coûteux qui est déplorable quand l'État
définit dans son rôle régalien le niveau
d'exigence pour l'éducation des enfants
ou pour le soin il est dans son rôle
mais la mise en oeuvre se fait par les
collectivités qui exécutent donc au nom
de l'État un certain nombre de
prestations donc je me réjouis quand
vous dites que l'État nous aide c'est
voilà c'est un minimum donc l'État doit
être là et que je pense que chacun l'a
dit à sa manière on mourra en bonne
santé sous le poids des normes parce que
les poids des nains finissent par
contrarier l'intention souvent vertueuse
ou du législateur ou de l'État parce que
nous sommes aussi dans une dans une
république on a vote un principe de
précaution
ça veut dire que le principe de
précaution nous amène à penser que rien
ne doit arriver pour nous distraire et
c'est tellement vrai que l'action qu'on
voudrait voir
se produire et se produit même pas parce
que c'est trop cher très long Rémy
pointeau Laly donc moi je pense que au
Sénat voulait rappeler nous sommes très
attachés au principe de qui décide paye
et que nous avons besoin d'un état très
fort et très puissant aucun cas nous
nous posons les deux mais que si un
binôme fonctionne bien ça irait mieux et
le qui décide paye vous avez raison
parce que
l'État encore une fois s'il décide
d'imposer des normes des obligations
pourquoi pas mais il ne peut pas se
contenter de demander aux collectivités
d'exécuter sa commande sans que celle-ci
était associée donc ça c'est un vrai
sujet ce qui amène madame la ministre a
demandé vous l'avez dit aussi une clause
de revoyure des transferts de
compétences je vais prendre le RSA
aujourd'hui on a même des départements
qui demandent à ce que ça renationalisé
puisque l'État transféré un moment avec
une enveloppe financière sauf que l'État
n'a pas cessé de rajouter des
obligations et des normes ça renchérit
les choses et les départements n'ont pas
vu l'enveloppe redistribuée enfin Madame
la Ministre on est tous d'accord autour
de la table
elle doit être nécessaire et que je
pense on l'a dit vous avez eu la
gentillesse de rappeler la charte
d'engagement que nous avons l'intention
de suivre de près
une loi elle doit d'abord faire l'objet
d'une évaluation de sa nécessité c'est
ce qu'on appelle une étude d'option
est-ce qu'il est nécessaire de mettre à
nouveau texte ou est-ce qu'on a tout ce
qu'il faut dans l'arsenal législatif qui
est quand même assez complexe et puis on
a un vrai sujet Madame le Ministre
l'étude d'impact est faite par qui par
le ministère qui défend le projet de loi
alors moi j'attends avec impatience que
le ministère qui porte un projet de loi
il s'est beaucoup trop cher c'est pas
bon on va diminuer donc franchement on a
un problème de de un peu de méthode de
voir de bon sens et puis dernier point
et je ne serai pas plus long je voudrais
parler du pouvoir dérogatoire des
préfets pour qu'il y ait la
proportionnalité de la norme et je
donnerai un exemple très simple dans mon
département comme non certainement
beaucoup d'autres il y a une petite
place autour de la place il y a une
église une mairie une salle des fêtes
tout ça à 50 mètres de distance le maire
très consciencieux est remarquable mais
ces trois équipements aux normes
accessibilité on lui dit alors Monsieur
le Maire c'est parfait donc il vous faut
deux places pour handicapés pour
l'église de place pour la mairie de
place pour la salle des fêtes personne à
la commission d'accessibilité ou il
préfet m'a dit on pourrait peut-être
regarder les choses quand les
clochtonnes le dimanche matin la mairie
est fermée d'accord et quand les gens
font la fête au village la mairie est
fermée
et l'église aussi et donc le maire il
s'est fait pardonner moi sévèrement
engueulé par ses concitoyens qui venait
à l'église au moment des enterrements ou
des mariages et il y avait au moins cinq
places de stationnement dédiées au
handicapés qui restaient vides et qu'on
ne peut pas utiliser
sauf
ice qu'elle a contravention et les gens
pourraient pas stationner alors
aujourd'hui on a fait bouger la loi mais
vous voyez l'exemple de proportionnalité
intelligente qu'on pourrait
attendre du préfet sans que le préfet
sollicite pour déroger à la règle
l'autorisation du ministère
de l'Administration centrale et puis
sûrement qui s'interroge aussi là dessus
sont les normes des fédérations
sportives qui sont pires parce qu'elle
ne rentre de compte à personne et elle
vous impose d'énormes sur les vestes à
la taille de foot et c'est très
compliqué merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci alors je vais vous
proposer peut-être d'abord commencer par
répondre à ces premières série de
questions posées par nos collègues de la
délégation
président
et puis on prendra trois les autres
questions à la suite donc je regarde
l'heure pour que chacun ne soit pas
frustré quand même temps il y ait des
vraies réponses
oui mais vous avez là vous avez
ouais
le poids des normes et en introduction
vous dire que évidemment je partage le
diagnostic et je suis
tout à fait prête à poursuivre les
travaux entamés simplement moi je ne
suis au gouvernement que depuis juillet
2022 je suis 2022 je ne suis député que
depuis je juillet 2022 et je fais partie
d'un gouvernement où la consigne est
très claire nous devons le moins
possible porter de texte et de loi et
quand nous portons des textes de loi qui
sont les plus courts possible qu'est-ce
que j'observe avec mon collègue
Christophe bichu depuis juillet
2022 c'est que chaque fois que je suis
au banc moi vous m'avez vu au banc
quatre fois cinq fois Christophe 4 x 5
fois sur des projets de loi qui sont
portés par vous ou bien à l'Assemblée
sur des parts dans des propositions de
loi qui sont portées par les députés
donc je n'ai pas là les chiffres pour
savoir par des parlons des douze
derniers mois mais je vais m'en enquérir
parce que je pense que comme je vous
l'ai dit dans mes propos liminaires en
fait notre responsabilité partager et il
est vrai que le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nous amène des textes moi je passe mon
temps à aller j'ai pas le temps de
travailler ce que j'aimerais porter
qu'il faut que j'aille répondre à des
projets donc regardons bien
objectivement pour pouvoir être capable
ensuite je prends l'engagement de
limiter le recours au procédures
d'urgence voilà donc le nombre de
saisines en urgence et d'extrême urgence
pour le cesen de cneen 17% des textes
ont été examinés en urgence en 2022
contre 13% 2021 donc il y a encore une
inflation 2022 donc 6 % des textes ont
été examinés en extrême
urgence en 2022 contre
2%. donc on voit que
urgence moyenne 17 13 on est passé 17 et
extrêmement urgence de deux on est passé
à 6 donc le sujet vaut la peine d'être
investi parce que je sens puisque vous
mettez l'accent dans votre rapport et
vous dans votre mission sur ce sujet
avec les propos que je pense vous savez
sincère je vous dire à quel point nous
ne voulons pas
créer de l'inflation bien au contraire
il nous faut simplement être extrêmement
vigilant ensemble pour
[Musique]
pour faire en sorte que on puisse alors
Monsieur Pointreau vous dites
sincérité des études d'impact que vous
ne remettez pas en cause
moi je pense que il y a de très bonnes
études d'impact et il y en a qui sont
fait trop à la va-vite et donc je
souscris sur je souscris à notre volonté
à notre détermination de faire en sorte
que ces études d'impact telles soient
faites comme elles le doivent et je ne
pense pas que ce soit parce que
l'administration travaille avec le
ministre qui porte le texte que l'étude
d'impact soit partisanes ça non par
contre leur laisser du temps pour le
faire de façon
dans le cas encore une fois et en
profondeur cela me paraît fondamental
donc je ne peux que souscrire à votre
proposition
ensuite Françoise Gatel sur justement
les études d'impact
alors je veux quand même rappeler que la
DGCL en sa qualité de secrétaire du cnen
analyse également les fiches d'impact
transmise par les ministères la trame
actuel des études d'impact liées au
projet de loi me semble par ailleurs
adapté dans la mesure où elle demande
bien au ministère d'une part d'avoir
consulté les parties prenantes
concernées par le projet texte donc il y
a ce contrôle qui est fait à la fois
dans le cadre de l'étude d'impact et par
la DGCL qui joue ce rôle de secrétaire
du CNN et d'autre part d'avoir étudié
les autres options possibles que celles
du recours à la norme
et donc le secrétariat général au
gouvernement est par ailleurs représenté
au sein du CNN et prend en compte les
remarques des membres élus du CNN sur la
qualité des études d'impact donc en
conclusion
je ne crois pas mais tout est
perfectible que la modification de la
trame des études d'impact
soit pertinente je souhaite plutôt faire
appel à la responsabilité collective des
différents acteurs concernés ministère
porteurs du texte des GCL SGG CNN afin
de garantir que ces études d'impact soit
correctement renseignées et utilisés
voilà en premier élément de réponse sur
vos prises de parole messieurs et Madame
merci Madame la Ministre la parole de
François bonhomme et Stéphane sotorel se
prépare
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
ministre d'être là pour ce sujet qui
nous occupe de manière récurrente
sans que nous puissions pour autant
épuiser le sujet et pour cause puisque
si on revient enfin on regarde un peu
rétrospectif on s'aperçoit quand même
que
le première chose c'est peut-être à
éviter
que l'on reste dans la seule déploration
mais VT aussi à notre écueil c'est celui
de la démangeaison parce que chaque fois
qu'on se réunit pour par les
simplification il en sort la perspective
de nouvelles de nouveautés de nouvelles
mesures qui parfois dans une espèce de
retour diabolique Vienne compliquer
encore les choses et c'est pas la
création de ministère
ou de secrétariat d'État à la
simplification qui vient
arranger les choses d'ailleurs je pense
que les ministres qui ont été chargés à
simplification sont tombées comme on dit
dans le l'été c'est à dire le fleuve de
l'oubli c'est peut-être la preuve aussi
que non pas que la solution a été a été
a été trouvée mais que on a constaté par
l'absurde que c'était pas de ce côté-là
tu viendra la lumière pas plus qu'elle
deviendra sans doute de la perspective
de créer des défenseurs de alors il y
avait 6 mois il y avait des propositions
pour faire défenseur des droits de
l'enfant
la Défenseur des droits des
collectivités je suis pas sûr qu'en soit
créer une nouvelle autorité
indépendante de me rendre quand on voit
parfois certaines pratiques il y en a
qui en sont faites viennent aussi
simplifier et surtout
résoudre le problème par contre ce que
je sais c'est que il y a moins de 10 ans
il y avait une ordonnance a été prise
qui porte sur la fameuse adapte s'il y a
l'accessibilité
programmée pour les ERP et que cette
mesure là sans qu'elle soit contestable
sur le fond a eu pour effet d'être de
côté plusieurs milliers en collectivités
locales à l'époque il y avait une
évaluation qui était de 11 milliards
d'euros ou 10 milliards d'euros
j'aimerais bien savoir aujourd'hui si
vous êtes en capacité par exemple de
nous dire donc 8 ans 9 ans après si vous
avez une évaluation fine de du coup de
cette ordonnance qui n'a jamais été
discutée sinon pour constater ce qu'elle
signifie en terme budgétaire et
financier pour les collectivités locales
voilà ce que je voulais vous simplement
vous dire à ce stade mais
c'est peut-être effectivement d'avoir
une disposition d'esprit Madame le
Ministre et peut-être vous rejoindre là
dessus c'est de ne pas céder à cette
espèce de démangeaisons réglementaire
pour précisément simplifier la lourdeur
de celle-ci et de faire preuve comme
dans d'autres domaines de sobriété
[Musique]
évoqué on a aujourd'hui un très bel
exemple avec tout ce qui décline de wiki
se ressortent de la loi climat et
résilience des carences des études
d'impact et et donc de la nécessité de
religiférer pour corriger des textes
récents dont la portée la mise en œuvre
de par la complexité de par la gestion
de paradoxe de politique publique nous
interpelle nous interroge et bloque en
fait le système ça c'était ma première
marche sur les impact et le deuxième
c'est c'est mais ça on est effectivement
vous avez raison Madame le Ministre tous
responsable c'est la complexité
croissante de toutes les politiques
publiques leur interaction qui font que
nous nous cherchons nous introduisons
toujours pour de bonnes raisons
d'énormes qui par ailleurs paralyse
d'autres politiques publiques et donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
s'interroger sur cette sur cette gestion
de la complexité pour peut-être avoir
une gouvernance qui est pas tout à fait
celle que nous avions jusqu'à lors un
troisième remarque porte effectivement
aussi sur le pouvoir de dérogation des
préfets je pense que c'est un sujet
majeur donc je me félicite que que la
mission reprenne ses conclus ces
éléments là dans ces recommandations et
on vit tous les jours en fait des
blocages autour de cette question là et
je pense que un des éléments majeurs qui
qui aujourd'hui limite ou bloque
l'application de cette de cette
dérogation c'est en fait la
responsabilité les conséquences selon la
personnalité des préfets qui peuvent
être induite par tel ou tel dérogation
et donc là aussi je ne sais pas sous
quelle forme mais je me félicite qu'on
aborde cette question là il conviendra
il conviendrait de trouver des moyens de
répondre à cette à cette question là
enfin dernier point financier sur sur
les compensations sans aller très très
loin sur le ce sujet qui prendrait des
heures je veux juste rappeler déjà
premièrement que la DGF n'est pas un don
mais un du parce que la DGF est en fait
le transfert financier qui répond en
fait à des choix fiscaux qui ont été
faits à un moment ou un autre par l'État
et qui fait que le les montants qui qui
proviennent de ces dotations pour les
collectivités sont en fait la
compensation d'un élément historique qui
a été mis en place et qui doit être
dynamique ça c'est le premier point le
fameux débat qu'on a pu avoir sur
l'indexation sur la DGF de de
l'indexation pendant de la DGF sur
l'inflation et deuxième élément la
nécessité bien évidemment de de revoir
et de réexaminer les compensations en
fonction de l'évolution de l'examen des
d'évolution des compétences et dernier
point qu'on évoque peu mais qui est
aussi une conséquence en tout cas je
l'ai entendu souvent dans les auditions
c'est la notion des délais c'est à dire
au-delà des coûts directs il y a les
coûts induits par les délais les délais
d'instruction les délais des procédures
qui font qu'on surenchérit un certain
nombre de projets
au-delà de de de la simple dimension
financière merci
sur les délais parce que le sujet de
délai n'était
peu un sujet lorsque la passion était à
0 et 1% lorsqu'elle a 7 % le délai ça
commence à être un peu plus cher
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je souhaitais vous interroger
sur un sujet extrêmement concret et
précis qui est celui du projet décret
pour relatif pardon au fil des deux
sécurité pour faire face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie lequel le dispositif a
été voté lors du projet de loi de
finance dernier pour 2023 ce projet de
décret a été présenté devant les élus du
comité des finances locales lesquels
élus ont dans leur totalité est mis un
avis défavorable en effet ce décret
semble peut-être je dois utiliser le
conditionnel il semblerait que ce décret
soit plus restrictif que ce que prévoit
la loi alors tout à l'heure on évoquait
une inflation normative ou évoquait vous
évoquiez on va dire l'examen de
proposition de loi en nombre de projets
de loi en nombre et bien donc nous
faisons le travail de parlementaire nous
en débattons ou les votons et puis c'est
décret que nous ne rédigions pas
évidemment les parlementaires et bien
ils s'avère que dans ce cas précis
il est tellement restrictif et c'est ce
que les élus du comité local du comité
des finances locales pardon on exprimé
des critères donc trop restrictifs
qu'ils craignent que le l'enveloppe qui
est dédié à ce filet de sécurité
prétendre 5 milliards d'euros c'est pas
rien on le souligne et bien en l'état ne
pourrait pas être utilisé dans sa
globalité tellement il est restrictif un
exemple précis même s'il y a eu quelques
petites avancées mais un exemple précis
concerne les collèges et les lycées ou
ce sont vraiment des bâtiments qui sont
énergivores et on sait que c'est
collectivités locales en responsabilité
ont des budgets qui ont explosé
concernant ces bâtiments là et bien il
semblerait que seuls les les hôtels du
département et les hôtels de Région
pourraient bénéficier de ces dotations
financières pour réaliser des prendre en
charge pardon cette évolution de dépense
énergétiques on sait bien que ce ne sont
pas ces bâtiments-là qui sont les plus
consommateurs d'énergie et ce n'est pas
à cause de ces bâtiments là que les
budgets ont pu exploser un bon nombre de
collectivités voilà ce que je voulais
évoquer avec vous et voir comment les
choses pourraient encore peut-être
comment on va dire être évolué et
prendre en compte la parole des élus qui
certes donc un avis consultatif
lorsqu'ils
comment on va dire quand il s'exprime
dans ce comité des finances locales mais
c'est un avis qui remonte du terrain et
je veux relayer ainsi et reprendre ainsi
les propos de mes collègues et ces avis
là remontent du terrain de ce qui ce
qu'ils vivent au quotidien et mettre un
peu de cohérence dans les décisions qui
sont prises notamment par le
gouvernement merci mes chers collègues
on va vous laisser répondre
[Musique]
souffler j'ai juste complété pour que
vous puissiez reprendre les fiches aussi
des collaborateurs que l'on connaît bien
juste pour vous dire qu'effectivement
l'exemple donné par notre collègue
Corinne ferait et c'est vu aussi je
crois sur le zan
il semble que le Sénat a repéré que les
décrets pris par l'État étaient un peu
plus respectifs que l'esprit de la loi
et que la loi telle qu'écrite et là
encore Corinne verrait nous démontre et
nous levons vu nous au Sénat mais les
Comité des finances locales ou Charles
Guinée nous représente brillamment
notamment il est ici présent et bien
s'en aperçoit aussi donc voyez et cela
crée
un sentiment de défiance
inutile entre les parlements les élus
locaux
et l'instance étatique pas le
gouvernement vous voyez ce n'est pas le
sujet
personnelle ou
immédiate on sent un système comme cela
de dérive entre ce corps aurait voulu
peut-être l'administration à binicio
dans un texte et puis ce que la loi est
et c'est ce côté où c'est la loi qui
prédomine dans la hiérarchie des normes
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
vos questions alors il y a quelques
questions que je pense nécessaire de
traiter vu l'heure qui ont été abordés
par vous madame la rapporteur et sur
lequel je vais vous donner un petit
éclairage d'abord brièvement vous dire
que et je vais essayer de répondre
ensuite à chacune de votre thématique
mais
sur le sujet des conférences de dialogue
que vous mettez en avant dans votre
propos
nous entendons l'importance que vous
accordez à cette proposition qui est
revenue à trois occasions on l'a vu dans
le rapport de la présidente Françoise
Gatel dans la loi 3DS et enfin votre
rapport sur la simplification des normes
adopter en janvier 2023 c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi je vous propose
d'expérimenter la mise en place de ces
conférences de dialogue à l'échelle
départementale voire infra départemental
auprès de préfet ou sous-préfet
volontaire l'objectif pourrait être
d'évoquer des difficultés d'application
des normes auxquelles les acteurs locaux
confronté de recueillir des propositions
de modifications législatives et
réglementaires possibilités l'argile par
la loi 3DS à l'ensemble des départements
et puis troisième objectif proposer des
mesures concrètes de simplification
parce que dans ce genre d'échange on
descend pas jusqu'à la loi qui pourrait
être supprimée au profit d'une autre ou
etc donc moi je suis assez partisan de
cette expérimentation si vous en êtes
d'accord donc
je me permets toutefois de tirer votre
attention sur le nécessaire bonne
coordination de cette conférence avec
les travaux conduits au sein des
conférences territoriales de l'action
publique je vous rappelle et c'était HAP
mise en place au niveau régional par la
loi de modernisation de l'action
publique territoriale et de
l'affirmation des métropoles la maptam
donc ça c'était pour rappeler à quel
point
ça doit être coordonné mais on est tout
à fait prêt à travailler sur trois
quatre cinq expérimentations ensuite
deuxième sujet qui me paraît important
parce que je ne vais pas y répondre
peut-être aussi favorablement que vous
pourriez le souhaiter c'est le sujet du
défenseur des libertés locales
allez-y allez-y
donc l'émission exercée par chacune de
ces entités je pense pas nécessaire de
vous les rappeler je l'ai un peu dit
dans ma déclaration générale le Comité
des finances locales d'une part et le
Conseil national d'évaluation des normes
d'autre part
il semble que les missions de chacune de
ces deux institutions le CFL dispose par
exemple de nombreux pouvoirs notamment
en matière de répartition de la DGF par
exemple ou de répartition du produit des
amandes de police serait sans doute
nécessaire de se saisir pleinement de
ces instants avant d'en créer des
nouvelles ensuite il me semble monsieur
le Président Madame la rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
cette fonction de défenseur
constitutionnel des libertés locales
elle est exercée par qui on est d'accord
elle est elle est décrite et déjà exercé
par le Sénat en sa qualité de
représentant des collectivités
territoriales donc c'est pour ça que
spontanément on a envie de dire ça
existe c'est fait c'est le Sénat et donc
il nous semble que c'est vous qui
veillez au quotidien au respect des
principes de libre administration des
collectivités et d'autonomie financière
fiscale j'ai l'impression que vous jouez
véritablement ce rôle il incombe à mon
sens au Parlement et non à une nouvelle
autorité administrative indépendante
etc donc ça c'est mes éléments de
réponse pour ce deuxième point et
Monsieur un de vous a parlé du rôle du
préfet
sur le pouvoir de dérogation du préfet
alors je rappelle des choses que j'ai
découvertes lors de d'une ou deux de mes
66 visites de terrain que j'ai fait
depuis juillet et j'ai vu des préfets
qui dérogaient et j'en ai vu d'autres
s'étonner de ces dérogations ça veut
donc dire que même dans les
représentants de l'État
en région et bien certains dérogent et
ils sortent trois le droit d'autres non
donc c'est important de rappeler que le
décret de 2020 relatif au droit de
dérogation du préfet liste cette matière
dans lesquelles ce pouvoir peut
s'exercer plus de trois quarts des
arrêtés interviennent dans une seule de
ces sept matières à savoir les
subventions et concours financiers dans
ce contexte je vous réaffirme ma volonté
d'inciter les préfets à faire davantage
usages de ce droit le président de la
République la première ministre nous le
rappelle dans des instances séparées
mais un conseil des ministres en réunion
des ministres demandez au Préfet de
faire parce que on peut pas parler de
différenciation si alors que c'est dans
le droit on ne rappelle pas au préfet
qui peuvent en faire usage voilà je
souhaite également simplifier la
procédure de dérogation plusieurs pistes
que je vous propose de simplification
sont actuellement à l'étude la
suppression de la saisine préalable
obligatoire du préfet de région par le
préfet de département
donc nous nous travaillons
la suppression de la saisine obligatoire
de l'administration centrale lorsque la
matière ne semble pas le justifier
et nous encourageons les préfets à faire
connaître les normes qui devraient selon
eux faire selon eux faire l'objet d'un
aménagement législatif au réglementaire
à l'initiative du gouvernement le sujet
est en lien avec les conférences de
dialogue état collectivité territoriales
que vous appelez de vos vœux dont je
viens de vous dire qu'on allait tenter
une expérimentation troisième sujet
c'était donc alors je pourrais vous en
dire beaucoup plus tu pourrais revenir
si vous le souhaitez mais je veux vous
dire quelques mots sur un sujet dont je
sais qu'il vous est cher qui est la
compensation des transferts de
compétences
qui
président des finances de département
vous dit que ça du même coûteux en
France donc la compensation des
transferts de compétences et
voilà on va être un peu être
probablement les j'ai des accords mais
vous proposez une instauration d'une
clause de revoyure par rapport à la
question du coût historique
donc je ne peux pas ne pas vous rappeler
la Constitution qui dit que tout
transfert de compétences entre l'État
les collectivités territoriales
s'accompagnent de l'attribution de
ressources équivalentes à celle qui
était consacrée à leur exercice le
principe ne prévoit donc pas de
réévaluation dans le temps que ce soit à
la hausse ou à la baisse de cette
compensation regarde l'évolution du coût
d'exercice de la compétence transféré et
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel et constante sur ce
point donc les compensations sont en
effet libre d'emploi et l'État n'a pas
vocation à en contrôler
l'utilisation de cette d'abord écarter
c'est notre position
l'hypothèse d'une compensation glissante
qui serait fondée sur l'actualisation
annuelle des dépenses engagées par les
collectivités au regard des compétences
transférées
tout à l'heure madame la sénatrice vous
avez dit monsieur le Président qui
décide paye et donc c'est
quand on a transférer une compétence
elle peut être faite à la main du
président de l'instance à laquelle elle
a été déléguée sur le maire ou le
président d'intercommunalité donc après
quand
il me semble
il me semble que une compétence
glissante une fois qu'on a passé la main
et que la responsabilité est à la main
de l'élu locale nous dire on voudrait
maintenant que la compensation ne soit
pas lignée sur il y a 10 ans et ces dix
dernières années et aujourd'hui mais sur
plutôt des années toute récentes quand
la compétence est transférée depuis de 3
ans par exemple bon ça paraît
[Musique]
ça paraît difficile voilà le principe
selon lequel les élus doivent assumer le
coût financier de leur décision dans
l'exercice de la compétence transférée
semble sain les collectivités on peut
débattre on peut débattre les
collectivités peuvent ainsi librement
décider d'augmenter ou de baisser les
montants consacrés aux compétences
transférées indépendamment du niveau des
ressources transférées leur exercice par
l'État et je souhaite rappeler que
certaines ressources transférées pour
assurer la compensation de compétences
sont dynamiques dans le bon sens et
parfois beaucoup plus que l'inflation
c'est le cas de la TSCA mais pour le
financement des 10 dont la dynamique est
plus que notable le produit affecté au
département est passé de
843 millions d'euros
à un milliard 238
soit une augmentation de 46,9% sur la
période en revanche le critère de
répartition de cette compensation est
faiblement révélateur des charges
réellement supportées par le département
en matière de 10 dans la mesure où la
compensation a été effectuée lors du
transfert à partir du nombre de
véhicules terrestres enregistrés dans le
département donc j'entends le désaccord
et je trouve même votre demande
tout à fait légitime mais j'ai un autre
avis qui est celui du gouvernement mais
il se trouve que je le partage et voilà
donc je tiens à rappeler que l'État est
parfois revenu sur le principe de la
compensation historique afin d'ajuster
le montant de la compensation c'est le
cas du financement de revenus de
solidarité active le RSA pour le
département donc la loi de finances pour
2020 avait ainsi mis en place un
dispositif de compensation péricway qui
a permis de transférer au profit des
départements la totalité des frais de
gestion perçus par l'État au titre de la
taxe foncière sur les propriétés Bapti
pour un milliard d'euros et la
possibilité de relever le taux plafond
de la taxe publicitaire publicitaire
ou du droit d'enregistrement donc c'est
un deuxième exemple droit de mutation à
titre onéreux les fameuses DMTO et qui
est passé de 3,8% à 4,5 pour 2 milliards
d'euros et puis le fond de solidarité en
faveur des départements le FSD donc
l'idée c'est de vous donner les
éclairage qui est le mien aujourd'hui
ensuite je voudrais aller quelques mots
rapides sur les ERP accessible
il y a trois de nos collègues qui
veulent reprendre la parole alors même
si Madame leur rapporteur sera peut-être
obligé de nous quitter pour parce que là
les avions pour chez elle il y en a pas
toutes les 5 minutes donc on pourrait
parler aménagement du territoire il
vient
juste sur les ERP par contre
ça vous a peut-être échappé parce que
c'est super récent président de la
République a réuni toutes les parties
prenantes autour du jeu de
l'accessibilité et le gouvernement bon
s'est engagé à mettre en place un fond
territorial d'accessibilité de 150
millions d'euros par an pour soutenir
les investissements de mise en
accessibilité des bâtiments publics des
collectivités territoriales sur la
période 2024-2029
large et qui prévoyait initialement que
ce que prévoyait la loi initialement
parce que nous avons intégré les
dépenses de transport ferroviaire des
régions ce qui n'était pas prévu
initialement les critères
d'éligibilité ont été fixées par la loi
pas par décret voilà donc ces quelques
petits éléments maintenant moi j'ai une
réunion je vous écoute
oui assez rapidement pour que aucun de
nos collègues ne soit frustrés c'est
alors du coup assez brièvement Cédric
Vial Jean-Michel Houlgate et François
bonhomme voulait
avoir une précision André il viendrait
Richard mais vraiment très vite Cédric
merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre plus qu'une question
est contenue du contenu de la mission je
voulais comme Monsieur Mougeot faire
avancer le schmilblick
posant le la question de la complexité
administrative au réglementaire est
vraiment de l'impact sur les
collectivités en posant la question des
marchés publics je pense que c'est un
chantier le marché public est un
chantier sur lequel ça mériterait
peut-être qu'on se pose l'intérêt du
procédure de marché public c'est
normalement de permettre de choisir le
moins cher le moins 10 ans même si le
mieux le mieux disant en droit est quand
même dans 90% des cas le moins 10 ans si
vous choisissez un mieux disant autre
que -10 ans vous perdez au tribunal 9
fois sur 10 le
on est on est quand même beaucoup sur le
moins 10 ans mais admettons même le
mieux disant l'objectif c'est de faire
baisser les coûts et donc faire baisser
la charge publique concrètement
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
systématiquement la procédure de marché
public entraîne un surcoût pour tous les
travaux qui sont générés par les
collectivités et on est tu dis 30% moi
j'étais au moins sur 15 mais c'est à
dire que systématiquement
les entreprises qui répondent à les
marchés publics
mettent un surcoût de l'ordre de 15% qui
correspond pour eux à une anticipation
sur la complexité des procédures sur la
rigidité des procédures à terme ce qui
fait que ces procédures qui sont censés
faire des économies entraîne des surcos
deuxièmement les entreprises se
spécialisent sur le sujet c'est à dire
qu'on a les entreprises qui ne répondent
même pas celles qui pourraient peut-être
être moins cher etc de répondre même pas
et donc on arrive à un paradoxe ou non
seulement la collectivité vu la
complexité doit prendre des cabinets
d'assurance maîtrise ouvrage de maîtrise
de la voiture etc pour rédiger les
cahiers des charges prennent des risques
contentieux importants et en cours de
procédure en plus de ça la rigidité du
système empêche de de faire les choses
comme il faut si vous avez un jury donc
je pense que c'est une question sur
lequel il faudrait peut-être mettre
moins de règles a priori et plus de
règles et plus de contrôle
Jean-Michel Houlgate merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous avez
lancé une très bonne nouvelle à savoir
que le plan France réalité elle est
communiquée donc à la mi-juin le plan
France ruralité donc il vient succéder à
la jeune rurale avec 181 mesures donc
j'aurais vous parler justement de
l'évaluation puisque donc l'inspection
générale de l'environnement et du
développement durable donc vous a remis
en avril dernier donc un rapport parce
qu'ils ont passé aussi les 181 mesures
en étant parfois un peu circonspect sur
justement l'efficacité de ces mesures
alors justement est-ce que vous avez
tiré les enseignements de de cette
évaluation et est-ce que dans le cadre
de de ce plan France ruralité il va y
avoir de façon excentée des objectifs à
atteindre avec des indicateurs de
performance et puis à la suite comme
toute politique publique est-ce qu'il y
aura une évaluation post hantée pour
savoir si les objectifs ont été ont été
remplis je ferai juste une toute petite
remarque pour dire que la direction la
délégation collectivité territoriale qui
prend appui sur la division de la
législation comparée fait régulièrement
une actualisation de ce qui se passe au
Pays-Bas qui est un modèle en matière de
simplification administrative
Richard puis François bonhomme qui a
rien pour son deuxième tour il sera le
dernier merci monsieur le Président en
m'excusant de de mes entrées sorties
j'ai intervenir en séance donc peut-être
que des questions que je vais poser ont
déjà l'ont déjà été Madame le Ministre
semblement très clairement est-ce qu'il
y aurait des réflexions en cours au
niveau du gouvernement sur deux points
que je résume rapidement le pouvoir
réglementaire local non pas le pouvoir
réglementaire déconcentré mais local les
collectivités locales est-ce que c'est
une réflexion qui a à l'heure actuelle
l'heure de plaire au gouvernement
notamment dans le cadre peut-être d'un
projet de loi sur la différenciation etc
je ne sais pas ou sur les institutions
ça c'était ma première question très
concrètement pouvoir réglement pourquoi
je vous dis ça parce que moi je suis
alsacien et on a un droit local alsacien
mosellan qui pourrait mériter le cas
échéant d'être dupliqué ailleurs sous
voilà bon et la deuxième question c'est
nous avons eu l'une ou l'autre réflexion
au sein du groupe de travail sur un
projet de loi de finances
des collectivités locales comme il y a à
l'heure actuelle à un projet de loi de
finances de l'État un projet de loi de
finance naturellement de la sécurité
sociale est-ce qu'il y aurait de la part
du gouvernement des réflexions à cet
égard vous avez compris que les normes
enfin c'est le thème de notre de notre
mission les normes et toutes les
décisions prises
aggravent la situation financière des
communes sinon on serait pas là la
solution c'est naturellement d'avoir un
pourrait être d'avoir un projet de loi
de finance dédié
négocier etc est-ce qu'il a des
réflexions en cours à cet égard merci
Madame
non un projet un projet de loi de
financement
ça pourrait être le cas ça pourrait être
le cas si c'est le cas tant mieux les
collectivités ce serait ce serait bien
voilà lui ce serait ce serait très bien
mais on va pas trop en demander
rapidement François tu as 30 secondes de
réaction parce que je t'ai vu non mais
c'est juste tellement vous m'avez parlé
de Madame ministre de meilleure 5 si
j'ai bien compris l'annonce du président
public pour l'accessibilité handicapé
moi j'ai vu Amir 5
sur 50 dans les annonces
gouvernementales
a supposé que soit mis à 5 pendant 5 ans
ça fait 300 millions juste pour resituer
vous m'avez je vous ai interrogé sur
est-ce que vous aviez pu faire une
évaluation à votre respective du coup
réel sur l'ordonnance de 2015 par
rapport à la date à l'époque c'était
évalué je me souviens à 11 milliards
d'euros donc est-ce que avec la DGCL je
pense que c'est facile on peut faire
remonter les informations dans chaque
préfecture pour savoir tout ce qui a été
mis au titre de de la date même en
déduisant j'allais dire toutes les DETR
qui sont qui ont accompagnés pour avoir
le coût réel ça serait quand même
intéressant parce que chaque fois on
annonce mais on n'a pas de vision
rétrospective c'est aussi important
juste après une autre précision
juridique excusez-moi sur le vous avez
signifié que le transfert de compétences
ces dernières années avait été un motif
d'aggravation des coûts transférés or à
ma connaissance la loi principale qui a
eu un matériaux c'est la loi neutre
d'août 2015 et c'était pas un transfert
de collectivité de transfert de
compétences d'État aux collectivités
locales c'est un transfert
essentiellement
une autre collectivités locales il y a
une simplement un élément à ma
connaissance qui a été une prise de
compétence c'était même pas un transfert
c'est pour clarifier une compétence
c'était la gymnapi donc juste pour que
vous nous clarifier les choses sur le
plan de ce que vous entendez comme la
cause une des causes de transfert
financier sur le transfert et
de compétences qui a ma connaissance n'a
pas eu entre l'État et collectivités
locales c'est-à-dire dans les années
quoi d'ailleurs madame Gouraud votre
prédécesseur parlez toujours de temps de
digestion et de temps de pause par
rapport à tout ce qui avait bouleversé
le paysage institutionnel
merci
c'est à vous madame la ministre vous
avez le temps de respirer quand même
pour rendre ça des fiches allez-y merci
monsieur le Président donc sur France
ruralité monsieur le sénateur
ça a été ma première demande je veux
dire c'est les fondements de mes travaux
la première ministre m'avait donné de
septembre de pardon de juillet à
décembre pour analyser voir et me faire
ma propre opinion sur l'efficacité de la
gendar rurale dans les territoires je
rappelle que c'était 180 mesures mais
aussi 10 milliards d'euros et que donc
dès qu'on a commencé dès novembre au
travers de groupes de travail que l'on a
animé avec plus de 300 personnes qui ont
participé plus le rapport d'évaluation
que vous citez que j'avais mandaté un
inspecteur qui a fait un travail
remarquable si vous l'avez lu et qui
sait être critique positive et très
objectif sur lequel évidemment on s'est
appuyé donc oui France ruralité sera
simple sera lisible oui il y aura en son
sein des objectifs des indicateurs et
des mesures d'efficacité
et voilà donc c'est un ensemble de
politiques publiques avec un socle
législatif qui sera présenté
probablement mis octobre et qui sera
annoncé par la première ministre avant
la fin du mois de juin voilà pour France
ruralité et sur sa lisibilité et la
mesure de l'efficacité au travers
d'indicateurs qui seront en son sein
ensuite vous posez deux questions
auxquelles tout simplement monsieur le
sénateur je ne sais pas répondre
donc la seconde je pense savoir y
répondre mais je pense que la réponse
est négative aujourd'hui moi je
travaille avec Christophe Béchu Bruno Le
Maire et Gabriel Attal sur le tout début
mais du projet de loi de finance 2024 à
ma connaissance il n'y a pas mais je
peux me tromper je reviendrai vers vous
si je me suis trompé de projet de loi de
finances de collectivité une réflexion
qui soit conduite pour isoler un projet
de loi de finances des collectivités
locales dissocier du projet de loi de
finances à ma connaissance on travaille
sur beaucoup de choses je me suis montré
assez ouverte mais en tout cas ah bon
mais ça tombe bien d'accord
donc voilà et ensuite vous demandez le
pouvoir réglementaire local sur la
dimension alsacienne est pertinente ce
que je peux dire c'est que aujourd'hui
il y a vraiment une réflexion qui est
conduite par le Sénat à laquelle le
président de la République sera très
attentif sur voilà les institutions et
je pense que il pourrait y avoir en
fonction de résultat de ces travaux il a
saisi Gérard archer le président du
Sénat et la saisie
la Présidence de l'Assemblée il a saisi
un certain nombre d'acteurs il a reçu
les élus locaux il va les recevoir donc
il y a toute une réflexion qui est
conduite et dans lequel
et dans lequel pourquoi pas mais je le
vois plutôt horizon 2024 s'il devait y
avoir des évolutions qui seraient le
fruit d'un travail beaucoup plus à mon
qu'il est en train de conduire avec tous
les acteurs et les parties prenantes que
j'ai cité madame la Première ministre et
ensuite il n'y a pas d'évaluation adap
mais on va voir ce que l'on peut faire
monsieur le sénateur
c'est intéressant mais c'est parce que
le Président de la République a pris
conscience parce que nous l'avons alerté
sur le fait que le fait d'avoir décalé
le la date butoir à laquelle on devait
avoir mis tous nos bâtiments publics en
accessibilité forcément il y a des
arbitrages qui ont été faits donc ça a
ralenti l'investissement et c'est pour
ça qu'il a décidé de mettre 150 millions
d'euros par an sur 10 ans peut-être
c'est le chiffre que vous donnez mais
sinon il peut avoir dit aussi le plus
d'un milliard d'euros parce que ça n'est
pas uniquement les collectivités locales
qui vont être aidées il va y avoir aussi
des acteurs privés les commerces sur
l'accessibilité
peut-être que le montant auquel vous
faites référence est plus large que le
que les collectivités locales uniquement
et puis sur la précision juridique je
l'ai bien noté il y a d'autres choses
que j'ai notées sans pour autant avoir
donné d'éléments de réponse
alors sur les marchés publics on a
plusieurs
contraintes moi je veux bien que l'on me
dise ce que je suis en mesure de dire
sur ces sujets mais moi je les considère
comme vous extrêmement rigide les deux
sujets que j'ai fait travailler depuis
que je suis là en fait c'est le droit
européen qui nous contraint c'est-à-dire
on est en déclinaison du droit européen
donc sur non mais je ne dis pas que on
est contraint par le droit Robert je dis
simplement que pour avoir questionné le
sujet des marchés publics sur deux
sujets j'en prends un de mémoire qui est
l'expérimentation qui montre que jusqu'à
150000 euros pour choisir une start-up
qui vous propose des
luminaires mais des lampadaires des
d'éclairages publics à intégrer avec des
LEDs bien sûr mais aussi avec des
capteurs à reconnaissance de forme et
qui donc vous permet d'être allumé
éteint et bien cette startup et il y en
a trois en France aujourd'hui quand on
est dans le champ expérimental on peut
aller que jusqu'à 150000 euros en fait
je voulais qu'on aille au moins jusqu'à
400 000 euros pour que tout le monde le
teste et que on soit beaucoup plus
économe beaucoup plus vite en déployant
au lieu d'aller chercher des
investissements par le fond vert
actuellement qui sont dans un rapport de
1 à 4 sur le coup du lampadaire
et qui sont beaucoup plus économes en
fonctionnement pour les raisons que je
ne citer parce que là le lampadaire il
est écrit très faiblement quand il y a
personne et puis quand il y a un piéton
qui passe un vélo ou une voiture ou une
jeune fille qui descend pour aller chez
elle alors le lampadaire c'est clair
donc sur des sujets comme ça on est
contraint par ce 150000 euros qui limite
par exemple mais c'est pas ce que vous
me demandez c'est plus général mais je
m'engage à le regarder de façon plus
précise si tenter que l'on en est le
pouvoir et qu'on soit pas content par le
droit européen merci beaucoup à vous
pour cet échange et tout autre question
à laquelle j'aurais pas eu le temps de
répondre je suis à votre entière
disposition avec mon cabinet avec la
DGCL qui m'a accompagné dans cette
rencontre si madame la ministre pour
l'honnêteté la clarté de vos réponses et
d'avoir tenté de répondre à tout avec
beaucoup de simplicité mais il n'y a pas
de pièges donc ça nous permet d'échanger
dans notre travail sénatorial dans le
travail de contrôle du gouvernement et
de propositions merci à Françoise Gatel
et à toute sa délégation sa petite
troupe
voilà
d'élite des livres de rouge évidemment
bien sûr merci à vous